à 31 ans il fait aujourd'hui partie des
anciens du fc versailles 78 oussama
berka qui est au club depuis les moins
de 15 ans avec une petite parenthèse de
deux ans à mantes-la-jolie avec les
versailles et il a tout connu et
plusieurs montées de la dhr jusqu'à la
nationale 2 je suis content pour le club
pour moi
on devait en cfa depuis au moins cinq
six ans après ça s'est pas fait avec des
montées raté à des trois points mais
mais c'était la suite logique pour un
club comme versailles depuis des années
enfin depuis que je suis là moi je suis
là ça fait longtemps et on a toujours
joué les premiers rôles sajoo et sa joie
4 5 points la montée à chaque fois hélas
depuis que le coach est là on a toujours
joué les premiers rôles aujourd'hui ce
milieu de terrain réalise l'une des plus
belle saison de sa carrière versaillaise
avec à la fois une première place en
nationale 2 une demi finale de coupe de
france face à nice ce mardi 1er mars une
première pour le club c'est magnifique
allée en demi finale de coupe de france
franchement je pense qu'on s'en rend
même pas compte nettement se rend même
pas compte qu'on fait partie des quatre
dernières équipes en france mais on le
vit plutôt bien dans la joie la bonne
humeur comme d'habitude un match
historique qui ne pourra pas disputer
oussama berka qui est suspendu pour la
rencontre
malheureusement j'ai pris trois jaunes
ce qui fait que je suis suspendu
je suis frustré mais bon on avance ses
navires le pascal oussama a tout de même
accompagné ses coéquipiers lors de leur
voyage à nice il sera dans les tribunes
de l'allianz riviera pour ce match de
coupe de france en espérant pouvoir
réaliser l'un de ses rêves avec son club
de coeur jouer la finale au stade de
france